(soft music)
- I was delighted to serve
as Co-chair of the President's Committee
on Diversity, Inclusion, and Belonging.
Their work is very important,
for our society and for our University,
but it's not easy.
I was tremendously
impressed by the expertise,
generosity and thoughtful contribution
of each member of the committee.
Each one of them brought a different kind
of expertise to the table,
their knowledge and experience,
their commitment to deep discussions
and their collective wisdoms allowed
us to continue our work
during a very challenging
spring and summer,
and to produce a report
for President Salovey,
that I think we can all be proud of.
The report builds on previous
University initiatives
and proposes a forward looking framework.
I am confident,
that the group's recommendation
will serve here well,
for many years to come.
- I'm Ann Kurth the Dean of
the Yale School of Nursing.
It's a good moment to have
this report coming out,
the COVID-19 crisis,
has really demonstrated
the racial disparities in health care
that black indigenous people of color
and other populations have suffered
from in our country for many years.
This is a timely moment,
it's a pivotal one,
the nation is calling for justice
and Yale can respond,
Higher education needs to
be a part of this movement.
At the School of Nursing,
we are making Diversity,
Equity, Inclusion,
Belonging, and Anti-racism work a priority
because we must reflect
the communities we serve
in the way that we educate,
practice and conduct research,
much learning has to happen
and I'm learning also,
white people, must listen with intention
to our BiPAP colleagues,
friends, students, and loved ones,
we've spent 400 years
centering white voices,
now we must center the voice stories
and narratives of our BiPAP
members of our population
and support, their needs to thrive.
Nothing less, would be right
as an Institution and
as a larger community,
Yale as always can lead by example
and take bold action,
this report is a step in that direction.
- My name is Darin Latimore,
I am deputy Dean of
Diversity, Equity, Inclusion
at the School of Medicine.
I first wanna say it was an honor
to be on the President's Committee.
Each of us, looks at these
issues through our own lenses
however, it was immediately clear
that all of us felt a strong commitment
to creating a just environment
at Yale University.
I also wanna thank our community,
many of us interviewed
students, staff, and faculty
in order to get the
information that we needed
to create the most robust plan possible.
I'm very grateful that
I was on the Committee
because at the same time,
I was actually developing a strategic plan
for the School of Medicine.
It was really helpful
to be able to see what the University
is doing in the DEI space,
as I created my plan
because I wanted to make
sure that the strategies
that I use at the Medical School,
are in line with the strategies
that the University as a whole are using,
and the outcomes that I am measuring
are the same ones that the University
as a whole are measuring.
I like to say,
when we're all going
in the same direction,
working together, there's
a much better chance
that we'll get the outcome that we want.
- Hello, my name is Weili Cheng,
I am the Executive Director of
the Yale Alumni Association.
The mission of the Yale
Alumni Association States,
Our character, strengths and
values come from our diversity
and our commitment to a culture
of inclusion and equity.
Our mission is to enhance and renew
the lifelong Yale
experience for all alumni,
whoever they are and wherever they may be.
So who are our Alumni?
Our Alumni Community is a diverse group
that spans generations, identities,
Yale affiliations, and interests.
So our core value
of the Yale Alumni
Association is Inclusion.
What does Inclusion mean?
It means that we strive
for full engagement
and a sense of belonging among our Alumni.
All of our Alumni have had the privilege
of experiences and opportunities at,
and because of Yale,
these experiences and
opportunities influence
our choices and decisions and in turn,
these choices and decisions
can positively impact our communities,
especially if there is an understanding
of Diversity, Equity,
Inclusion, and Belonging.
At this moment in time,
we have an opportunity
and an obligation to advance
these important principles,
they are priorities for
the Yale Alumni Association
and for the University.
- I remember so clearly those meetings
after we received our charge
from President Salovey,
to shape the next phase
of University's work
on Diversity, Equity and Inclusion,
as well as Belonging.
What a great committee,
and we had some really
amazing conversations.
So many members of the committee,
have expertise in these areas
or have been citizens of the University
for a very long time,
so they understand our culture.
We talked often about how this work,
is more of a marathon and not a sprint.
We reviewed the work,
that has been done by generations
of students and faculty, staff, and alumni
We talked to a lot of people on campus,
and we compiled a pretty amazing list
of every project that's currently underway
or being planned in the schools
and then the Administrative Units.
I began to think of this
whole project differently,
the Committee's recommendations
and the President's priorities,
not so much as a marathon,
but as a part of a relay race.
Individuals complete marathons, right?
But teams actually compete in relay races
and each person, leg, has
its individual contribution
that's unique to that person.
So the Committee's work,
is really about passing the baton,
the baton, if you will,
toward a more inclusive, a more diverse,
a more excellent Yale,
a Yale where every member,
feels a sense of belonging
and that baton, has a common vision,
a guiding principle and goals
to align the work that's being done,
work that spans schools
and generations, identities, and views.
That baton also includes actions
for the first five
years, of this next phase
and all of this, by the
way, can be found online.
Yes, we're moving into the
next phase of this race,
and we have the ability
to create real change
and together, that is what we will do.
We all belong here, we all belong to Yale.
So let's make sure that
we show up for ourselves
and for each other,
let's make sure that this
part of the journey, counts.